à evian l'équipe de france de football a
fourbi ses armes avant de rencontrer la
yougoslavie en un match dont
l'importance n'échappe à personne
vous connaissez la composition de cette
formation qui luttera pour participer à
la coupe du monde notre région sera
représentée à belgrade par des joueurs
de l'olympique lyonnais et de
l'association sportive de saint-etienne
qui comme les mousquetaires
dès le coup d'envoi toucheront derrière
robert herbin arrière central 26 ans
entre 24 ans à lens entre ma seule
bourgade 1 2 buts 5 1
que représente pour vous ce match france
hugo s'est mis dans le match de sa vie
de reposante pour nourrir 1 preuve à la
qualification pour la coupe du monde
tendent à gagner deux premiers matches
contre le luxembourg et la norvège pour
la qualification de la coupe du monde il
faut faire un résultat là bas c'est un
match très important parce que c'est
comme ils ont pas l'avenir de
tout le football est un jeu parce que ça
va pas jusque là quand même à faire
c'est très important même puisque se
décident de la qualification la
combinant si on fait si il en arrive à
faire un bon résultat à belgrade on aura
de grandes chances de ballons finales
des coupes du monde mais si on perd
là-bas ce sera difficile il faut
l'aborder avec un état d'esprit de
gagnières il faut dire en france qui
vont entrer sur le terrain lire
aujourd'hui il faut il faut sortir les
tripes
il faut gagner est-ce que vous allez
avoir une pensée toute particulière pour
certains footballeurs qui sont illustrés
jadis en suède à la veille de ce match
bien sûr on espère on espère toujours
faire aussi bien que pour ses qualifiés
ou du monde si je crois que c'est le
rêve de tout footballeur ça nous fait
plaisir de pouvoir recommencer la belle
aventure qui ont vécu les joueurs qui
ont participé du monde en suède en 58
eh oui si le basque a su à lille en
finale de l'époque qui veut ça s'est
fait très beau c'est faire une coupe du
monde et je pense que chez nous il faut
qu'on essaie de faire pareil d'aller à
londres là même état d'esprit quelqu'un
qui sont rationnés je prends surtout ce
que pour
ce jeu vous même poste que moi
ces deux là pour vous savez que dans
l'équipe de la suède il y avait un
joueur à lyon qui nous apparaît
particulièrement qui était que je veux
d'ailleurs avec arrière gauche son poste
à timbrer laurent si je vous disais de
lui adresser un message maintenant
qu'est ce que vous auriez lui dire c'est
bien andré laurent fait partie de la
campagne de suède
je suis certain qu'il aurait il aimerait
que l'équipe de france aille à un nombre
non je pense que pour lui nous allons
essayer de lur berri tas
comment s'est passé ce stage à evian
très bien on a su bien amusé et enfin
elle en a respiré un bonheur le cal est
idéal pour se reposer c'est très bien
que ça n'a pas duré très longtemps
d'ailleurs il pleut maintenant alors il
vaut mieux retourner dans nos provinces
faire nos matches mais enfin ça s'est
bien passé dans l'ensemble
la ville est jolie enfin jean n'a pas eu
le temps de beaucoup la voient enfin le
coin très bien et je suis très bien
passé il ya une très bonne car il ya pas
de raison entre en fait ils ont péri en
8es ce côté là il ya une pompe camarades
il à l'équipe
c'est dommage c'était une peau qu un
grain j'aime à vous demander maintenant
quelle conclusion vous tirez à la suite
de ce stage d'evian et bien une seule
seul ce tout simplement que ce stage
atelier de renouer très facilement les
liens établis et disons aussi de revoir
avec tous les joueurs ce qu'ils avaient
été amorcées au cours de la tournée du
mois de février et mars
e les acteurs sont prêts quant à vous
les spectateurs
votre devoir est de les aider de les
encourager
ce match france hugo sa vie doit être la
première étape du renouveau du football
français